SECOND ASSEMBLY APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE HEARING.
NOTICE SEEN THE ABSENCE OF A
QUORUM WE'LL GO AHEAD AND START
AS A SUBCOMMITTEE IT LOOKS LIKE
YOUR FIRST MISTER JONES SAWYER.
IT LOOKS LIKE YOU ARE PRESENTING
ON A. B. TWENTY SEVEN NINETY
NINE IN AND ENJOYS A DO PASS
RECOMMENDATION ONCE WE GET
QUORUM.
NEITHER.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR AB TWENTY
SEVEN NINETY NINE WILL REQUIRE
AN APPLICANT FOR CANNABIS
LICENSE TO PROVIDE A STATEMENT
ALONG WITH THEIR APPLICATION.
AFFIRMING THAT THEY WILL ENSURE
THAT AT LEAST ONCE SUPERVISOR.
AND ONE EMPLOYER RECEIVED
TRAINING FROM CAL OSHA
THE CAL OSHA THIRTY HOURS
GENERAL INDUSTRY TRAINING MUST
BE COMPLETED BY SUPERVISOR AND
AN EMPLOYEE WITHIN ONE YEAR THE
CANVAS APPLICANT RECEIVING THEIR
LICENSE.
THIS JUST TO ENSURE THAT THE
CAMPUS INDUSTRY ADHERES TO THE
SAME SAFETY STANDARDS AS OTHER
INDUSTRIES.
THIS MEASURE WHAT WHAT HAVE
MINOR AND IT ABSORB APPLICABLE.
COST TO THE BUREAU OF CANVAS
TROLL.
EARLY MORNING HAVE HAVE MY
COFFEE.
TESTIFIED AND SUPPORTED THIS
BILL I HAVE JAZZY GRUEL FROM
UFCW WESTERN STATES COUNCIL OR
EXPECT LAST WEEK I VOTE.
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS GOOD MORNING MY
NAME IS JAZZ YOU GROW AND I'M
HERE ON BEHALF OF YOUR UNITED
FOOD AND COMMERCIAL WORKERS
WESTERN CHIEF COUNSEL.
REPRESENTING MORE THAN A HUNDRED
AND SIXTY THOUSAND WORKERS
INCLUDING MANY WORKING IN THE
CANNABIS INDUSTRY.
I'M HERE TO PRESENT ON AB TWENTY
SEVEN NINETY NINE WHICH HAS
RECEIVED BIPARTISAN UNANIMOUS
SUPPORT.
THIS BILL WOULD REQUIRE AT LEAST
ONE WORKER AND ONE SUPERVISOR TO
BE CERTIFIED IN THE CALISTHENICS
OUR GENERAL INDUSTRY COURSE.
WE HAVE RECEIVED INVALUABLE
TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE FROM
CALLERS SHUT AND THIS BILL WOULD
HAVE A VERY MINIMAL COST TO
IMPLEMENT. IS FOR THESE REASONS
RIVER CUSTER AYE VOTE ON AB
TWENTY SEVEN NINETY NINE THINK
YOU.
THANK YOU ARE THERE ANY OTHER
SPEAKERS IN SUPPORT.
SPEAKERS IN OPPOSITION.
I'M A FINANCE GOOD MORNING MADAM
CHAIR MEMBERS JULIA MADERA WITH
THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE I HAVE
NO VIOLENCE MEASURE THINK YEP.
SEE NOW QUESTIONS WOULD YOU LIKE
CLOSE RESPECTFUL ASK FOR YOUR
VOTE WILL TAKE THAT UP ONCE WE
HAVE A QUORUM AND DEXTER JONES
SAWYER
.
SEEN NOW AUTHORS IN THE AUDIENCE
WERE GONNA TAKE IT FROM
COMMITTEES SOME MISTER QUIRK.
HE WILL BE PRESENTING ON AB
TWENTY SEVEN TWENTY ONE IT
ENJOYS A DO PASS RECOMMENDATION.
GOOD MORNING CHAIRMAN MEMBERS
AB.
TWO SEVEN TWO ONE HAS A
NEGLIGIBLE FISCAL AFFECT ON THE
STATE AND REMOVES AMBIGUITY
REGARDING CANNABIS TESTING.
AB TWENTY SEVEN TWENTY ONE
CLEARLY PERMITS CANNABIS TESTING
LABORATORIES TO ACCEPT SAMPLES.
FOR PEOPLE TO GROW CANNABIS FOR
THEIR PERSONAL USE.
JOINING ME TODAY TO TESTIFY IN
SUPPORT.
YES SHE IS HERE. IS EMMA SNAGS
WITH THE CALIFORNIA CANNED
CANNABIS INDUSTRY ASSOCIATION
AND SHE'LL BE VERY BRIEF.
GIVEN THE OPPORTUNITY PRESENT
TODAY MY NAME IS EMMA SNAGS I'M.
CALIFORNIA CANNABIS INDUSTRY
ASSOCIATION OR CCI A.
THIS BILL PROMOTES HEALTH AND
SAFETY BY ALLOWING CALIFORNIA
CONSUMERS THAT ARE OF AGE IN THE
COMPLIANCE WITH THE LAW TO
ACCESS TO
UTILITIES.
TO ENSURE THAT THE PRODUCT
THEY'RE CULTIVATING A CONSUMING
MEET THEIR OWN STANDARDS I'M AB
TWO SEVEN TWO ONE DOES NOT ALLOW
TESTING LAB CERTIFICATION TO
PERPETUATE. ILLICIT MARKET FELL
THE CONSUMPTION AND DOES
DOCUMENT ALL TESTING ACTIVITY TO
CURB ILLICIT ACTIVITY. TEST WILL
BE RECORDED BY THE NECK WITH THE
NAME OF THE PERSON SUBMITTING
THE SAMPLE AND THE AMOUNT OF
CANNABIS A CANVAS PRODUCT
RECEIVED. DISSUADING ILLICIT
MARKET OPERATORS.
FROM USING TESTING TO ATTEMPT TO
LEGITIMIZE THEIR PRODUCTS LASTLY
AB TWO SEVEN TWO ONE HAS
NEGLIGIBLE STATE COSTS IF ANY.
FOR THE REASONS PREVIOUSLY
STATED WE ARE PLEASED TO SUPPORT
AB TWO SEVENTY ONE AND ENCOURAGE
YOUR SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU EITHER OTHERS SPEAKERS
INSPIRED.
SPEAKERS IN OPPOSITION.
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE NO FILE.
SEE NO QUESTION WOULD YOU LIKE
TO CLOSE.
RIGHT.
THANK YOU DOCTOR QUIRK.
I SEE THAT MISS BURKE IS IN THE
AUDIENCE.
AS BURKE I ASSUME YOU'LL BE
PRESENTING ON AB TWENTY SEVEN
FORTY ONE AND WAVING
PRESENTATION ON THE REST.
THANK YOU.
WE ARE SUBCOMMITTEE SO WE'RE NOT
HEARING.
BUT IT'S ALSO GET WHAT I'M
LEAVING SINCE WE JUST TALKED
ABOUT IT YEAH THIS ONE. AB
TWENTY SEVEN FORTY ONE ENJOYS A
DO PASS RECOMMENDATION AB TWENTY
SEVEN FORTY ONE SETS A FIVE DAY
LIMIT ON OPIATE PRESCRIPTIONS
FOR ACUTE PAIN MANAGEMENT FOR
MINORS WITH EXCEPTION FOR
CHRONIC PAIN MANAGEMENT HOSPICE
CARE. AND CANCER PATIENTS MINORS
WHO ARE UNDER TREATMENT FOR
SUBSTANCE USE DISORDERS AND IN
CASE OF EMERGENCIES.
AB TWENTY SEVEN FORTY ONE ALSO
REQUIRES A DOCTOR TO INFORM THE
MINOR'S PARENT OR LEGAL GUARDIAN
OF THE DANGERS AND RISKS
ASSOCIATED WITH THE OP A
PRESCRIPTION DRUG USE AND TO
RECEIVE CONSENT BEFORE
PRESCRIBING OPIOID MEDICATIONS.
I'M A FIVE DAY PRESCRIPTION
LIMIT FOR MINORS IS AN EVIDENCE
BASE AND DATA DRIVEN STRATEGY TO
REDUCE ADDICTION RATES ACCORDING
TO THE CDC THE LARGEST INCREASES
IN PROBABILITY OF CONTINUED USE
WERE OBSERVED AFTER FIVE DAYS.
AND THE THIRTY FIFTH FIRST DAY
OF PRESCRIPTION YOU OAKLEY IDEAS
WITH THAT. I HAVE A WITNESS
SINCE.
THANK YOU HI JENNIFER SOMOS WITH
THE MEDICAL BOARD OF CALIFORNIA
THE BOARD HAS A SUPPORTIVE
AMENDED POSITION ON THIS BILL
AND PROVIDING EDUCATION TO
PARENTS ON THE WRIST OF OPIATES
WILL HELP TO PROMOTE THE BOARD'S
MISSION.
ZOOMER PROTECTION THE BORDERS
WORKING WITH AUTHORS OFFICE ON
AMENDMENTS AND I RESPECTFULLY
REQUEST AYE VOTE WHEN YOU HAVE A
QUORUM THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
NATIONAL SPORT.
NAMELY THE DRONE ON BEHALF OF
THE OF THE CALIFORNIA CHAMBER OF
COMMERCE IN SUPPORT.
MARY WE CANNOT THE CALIFORNIA
DON'T ALSO ASSOCIATION AND
SUPPORT OF AMENDED.
OUR CONCERNS JUST BASICALLY
ARISE OVER.
IF THERE'S GONNA BE A CONSENT
FORM IF IT'S GONNA BE AROUND.
IF THAT MEDICAL BOARDS GOING TO
BE.
NO CREE NOT FORM THEN.
ANY PRESCRIBER THEIR LICENSING
BRIDGE SHOULD BE CREATING THOSE
FORMS AS WELL BUT IT'S GOING TO
BE ANYTHING ELSE WERE WILLING TO
WORK WITH THAT OFFERS OFFICE AS
WELL THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. MAY TAKE A BREAK REAL
QUICK SO WE CAN ESTABLISH
CORMACK THAT'S OKAY MADAM
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
GONZALEZ FLETCHER.
BIGELOW.
BLOOM.
BONTA.
BROKE.
CALDERON.
CARILLO.
CHECK OUT.
EGGMAN.
FONG FRIEDMAN.
GALLAGHER.
GARCIA.
DOES AARON.
OBERNOLTE.
QUIRK. HERE REYES.
AS ONE AND UP MR GARCIA'S HERE.
EVEN THOUGH HE DIDN'T SAY IT.
ALRIGHT WE NOW HAVE A QUORUM SO
YOU MAY PROCEED THIS ENJOYS A DO
PASS RECOMMENDATION OF A MOTION
BY MS FREEDMAN.
AND A SECOND BY MISTER OBERNOLTE
AND DO I THINK WE'RE AT SPEAKERS
IN OPPOSITION OF THEIR ANY.
SEEING NONE.
THE NOT LIVES. I THINK QUESTIONS
SEEN NINE YOU CAN GO AHEAD AND
CLOSE I RESPECTFULLY REQUEST AN
IRA.
THINK YOU KNOW.
RIGHT THAT GETS OUT.
WITH THE REPUBLICANS NOT VOTING
BUT MISTER OBERNOLTE VOTING I.
HEY IS MY BASIC MATH SKILLS THAT
TIME ACCOUNT.
OKAY I WILL AND BE HAPPY TO TAKE
A MOTION ON AB TWENTY SEVEN
TWENTY ONE MISTER QUIRK.
SO MOVED.
I TAKE THE MOTION FROM MISTER
CHOW IN A SECOND FROM MISS RAY
AS ON MISTER COURTS BILL.
THAT GETS OUT WITHIN A ROLL
CALL WITH MR FUNG NOT VOTING.
WE I WILL WAIT ON THE JONES
SAWYER BILL.
MR GARCIA WOULD YOU LIKE TO GO
AHEAD AND PRESENT.
IT'S MISTER DARCY I HAVE YOU
DOWN FOR PRESENTING AB TWENTY
SIX THIRTY SIX AND ENJOYS A DO
PASS RECOMMENDATION AND THEN
YOU'RE GOING TO PRESENT ON
BEHALF MISTER SANTIAGO IS THAT
CORRECT.
ALRIGHT WE'LL START BETWEEN SIX
THIRTY SIX.
THANK YOU GOOD MORNING. PRISON
AB TWENTY. SIX THIRTY SIX THIS
BILL IS A PROCEDURE MEASURE THAT
WOULD CREATE THE ENVIRONMENT
JUSTICE FUND. INTO WHICH THE
CALIFORNIA ATTORNEY GENERAL MAY
DEPOSIT MONEY TO PROVIDE SUPPORT
FOR THE NEWLY CREATED BUREAU OF
ENVIRONMENTAL JUSTICE.
RESPECT WE ASK FOR APPLE.
THEY'VE MUCH MY MISTRESS A
SECOND BY MISTER QUIRK.
YOU SPEAKERS IN SUPPORT.
SPEAKERS IN OPPOSITION.
I MEAN FINANCE NO FILE.
AT AT THE MISTRESS HAS QUESTION.
SHE GARCIA.
I REALLY LIKE YOUR BILL AND WITH
YOUR PERMISSION I'D LIKE TO ADD
ON AS A CO AUTHOR.
ALRIGHT. LET'S WE ARE CLOSE
MISTER GARCIA.
THAT GETS OUT ON A B. ROLL CALL
THANK YOU.
SCOTT HAVE YOUR TONGUE TODAY
MISTER GARCIA.
YOU ARE PRESENTING AB TWENTY
THREE NINETY TWO BY MR SANTIAGO
ENJOYS A DO PASS RECOMMENDATION.
AB TWENTY THREE NINETY TWO MAKES
A NUMBER OF CLARIFICATIONS THE
CHANGES TO THE. LOOPHOLES IN
CALIFORNIA'S TOWING A VEHICLE
STORAGE LAW. TO REDUCE ABUSIVE
PRACTICES AIMED AT INVADING
STORAGE FEES RESPECT THAT'S
RIGHT LEYVA MOTION BY MISTER
ESTES SECOND BY MISTER
OBERNOLTE.
ARE THEIR WITNESSES IN SUPPORT
BRIEFLY.
MADAM CHAIRMAN MACHINE LEVINE IN
BEHALF OF AMERICAN INSURANCE
ASSOCIATION SUPPORT THANK YOU.
KURT BLACKBURN ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA TO CHECK ASSOCIATION
IN SUPPORT.
ADDITIONAL SUPPORT BECCA KRAMER
MATTER ON BEHALF OF THE ACLU
CALIFORNIA
SUPPORT.
MY CARE WITH WESTERN CENTER ON
LAW AND POVERTY ALSO IN SUPPORT.
ANY OPPOSITION.
SCENE NINE DEPARTMENT FINANCE NO
FILE.
SEEN A QUESTION WE HAVE A MOTION
AND A SECOND.
.
THAT GETS OUT UNABLE COLLEGE
THINK YOU MISTER GARCIA FOR
STEPPING IN FOR MR SANTIAGO.
I WE'RE GONNA YES IF I CAN GET A
MOTION ON AB TWENTY SEVEN NINETY
NINE BY MISTER JONES SAWYER BY
ME I GOT MOTION BY MISTER
CALDERON A SECOND BY MISTER
QUIRK THAT GETS OUT OF THE ROLL
CALL.
MOVING ON IT LOOKS LIKE MR
FRAZIER.
YOU'RE GONNA BE PRESENTING ON A.
B. THIRTY ONE THIRTY FIVE IT
ENJOYS A DO PASS RECOMMENDATION.
THE MOTION BY MISTER A SECOND BY
MISTER QUIRK.
THANK YOU ARE THEIR WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT.
ANY OPPOSITION THAT ONCE
REGISTER THEIR OPPOSITION.
I CAN TELL SHE'S WALKING THE
MICROPHONE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE.
THE FRANCHISE TAX BOARD
ESTIMATES AT THIS BILL WOULD
REDUCE GENERAL FUND REVENUES BY
EIGHT THOUSAND DOLLARS ANNUALLY
BEGINNING IN TWO THOUSAND
NINETEEN TWENTY.
THE FRANCHISE TAX BOARD STATES
AT THIS BILL WOULD NOT
SIGNIFICANTLY IMPACT IT'S
MINISTRY OF COSTS.
WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE ON YOUR
EIGHT THOUSAND DOLLAR BILL.
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR VOTE.
GREAT THAT GETS OUT ON A B. ROLL
CALL WITH MR FUNG NOT VOTING.
THANK YOU MISTER FRAZIER.
MISS CARILLO.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
SORRY AND JUST
I CAN ON SOME
HOLD.
THANK YOU MR LOW.
WILL BE PRESENT AB THIRTY
THIRTY FOUR ENJOYS A DAY PASS
RECOMMEND.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH THIS
ASSEMBLY GIVES THE PUBLIC
EMPLOYMENT RELATIONS BOARD
JURISDICTION OVER LABOR DISPUTES
FOR THE SUPERVISORY UNITS FOR
PART I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR A
VOTE TODAY WITH ME IN SUPPORT
PRIDE HOUSE IN WITHOUT.
MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE BRIAN NELSON ON BEHALF
AMERICAN FEDERATION OF STATE
COUNTY MUNICIPAL.
EMPLOYEES AYE HERE TO ASK FOR
YOUR SUPPORT.
FOR ASSEMBLY BILL THIRTY THIRTY
FOUR.
WANT TO FIRST THANK THE
COMMITTEE CONSULTANT FOR THE.
THE SHARP ANALYSIS DONE.
IS OF RELATIVELY.
NEGLIGIBLE FISCAL COSTS
ASSOCIATED WITH THIS BILL.
AND QUITE HONESTLY THIS IS THIS
JUST PROVIDES A FRAMEWORK FOR US
TO ESTABLISH A NEUTRAL.
THIRD PARTY WITHIN THE STAB WAS
COMPREHENSIVE LABOR RELATIONS
STATUTE AND PRECEDENT TO DEAL
WITH.
MATTERS MOVING FORWARD.
WITH RESPECT TO THE TWO HUNDRED
SEVENTY EMPLOYEES AT.
THE PA. BART DISTRICT.
WHO ARE SUPERVISORY CHECKING UP
PROFESSIONAL TECHNICAL IN
NATURE?
WE WOULD AT RESPECTFULLY
REQUEST AN AYE VOTE.
THE MOTION I MISS CARILLO.
IT THE SECOND TIME MISTER CHAO
THANK YOU. JOSTLED WILK WITHOUT
SUMMIT IS HERE ANSWER TEST NO
TECHNICAL QUESTIONS.
ADDITIONAL SUPPORTERS.
I THEIR OPPOSITION.
GOOD MORNING MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS JIM LIGHTS ON BEHALF OF
THE SAN FRANCISCO BAY AREA RAPID
TRANSIT DISTRICT.
WE DO HAVE SOME DIFFERENT
THOUGHTS ON THE COST TO THE
DISTRICT IN COMPLIANCE WITH THIS
PROPOSAL AND I'D LIKE TO
INTRODUCE MICHAEL JONES
ASSISTANT GENERAL MANAGER WITH
PART TWO.
TO THAT.
GOOD MORNING I'M MADAM CHAIR
COMMITMENT COMMITTEE MEMBERS A
MY NAME IS MICHAEL JONES AND THE
ASSISTANT GENERAL MANAGER OF
ADMINISTRATION AT THE SAN
FRANCISCO BAY AREA RAPID TRANSIT
DISTRICT.
A BART POSES AB THREE ZERO THREE
FOUR.
FIRST WE BELIEVE THIS BILL
CREATES A NEW STATE MANDATE WITH
SIGNIFICANT REIMBURSABLE COST
BAR.
I WE ESTIMATE THAT NEW
ADMINISTRATIVE COST OF ABOUT
NINETY FIVE HUNDRED DOLLARS PER
DISC BICU REFERRAL TO PER.
A AND WE HAVE ISSUES THAT COULD
BE UNDER DISPUTE IN THE
NEIGHBORHOOD OF ABOUT A TWELVE
OR THIRTEEN.
.
THAT.
BUT ESTIMATES ABOUT A HUNDRED
AND.
THIRTY FIVE STUDENT HUNDRED
FIFTY THOUSAND DOLLARS.
.
PER.
A DISPUTE.
ADDITIONALLY TO FULLY UNDERSTAND
THE NEW PROCESS UNDER THEM AND
BE A PART WOULD NEED TO EMPLOY A
TECHNICAL. CONSULTANTS.
AT AN ESTIMATED COST OF ABOUT A
HUNDRED AND FIFTY THOUSAND UP
FURTHERMORE TO MANAGE THE MBA
PROCESS WOULD NEED TO HIRE AT
LEAST THREE NEW PEOPLE.
AT AN ANNUAL COST OF
APPROXIMATELY FIVE HUNDRED AND
THIRTY FIVE THOUSAND.
.
IN TOTAL THIS IS A POTENTIAL
REIMBURSABLE COST OF NEARLY
EIGHT HUNDRED THOUSAND DOLLARS
IN THE FIRST YEAR.
NECKS A IT WOULD BE A GREATER
FISCAL IMPACT TO THE STATE THAN
A MODEST COST OUTLINED IN THE
COMMITTEE ANALYSIS.
THE ANALYSIS SUPPOSES THAT ONLY
A MINOR NUMBER. OF DISPUTES EACH
YEAR.
HOWEVER BASED ON THE CURRENT
NUMBER OF DISPUTES BETWEEN BART
AND THE EMPLOYEE UNION THE
FISCAL IMPACT TO THE STATE WOULD
BE MUCH HIGHER THAN THE FORTY
THOUSAND. A DOLLAR ESTIMATE FOR
THESE REASONS MARK OPPOSES A. B.
THIRTY THIRTY FOUR RESPECTFULLY
ACTUALLY AN OBOE.
THANK YOU KNOW IS THERE
ADDITIONAL OPPOSITION.
I FINANCE NO FILE.
I THINK MISTER QUIRK HAS
QUESTION.
YEAH SHOW FOR THE PROPONENTS.
A TECHNICAL QUESTION WHY IS
THERE THIS BIG DIFFERENCE IAN
ESTIMATES OF COSTS.
AND AND HOW DO YOU BAY ISSUERS
I'VE HEARD HOW THE BASE THERE'S.
PART IS BASING OF THEIR COSTS
IT APPEARS ON.
EVERY DISPUTE THEIR CURSE
BETWEEN THE EMPLOYER.
AND OUR MEMBERS AS GOING TO PER
WHICH WILL BE THE CASE.
RARELY DO DISPUTES RISE TO THE
LEVEL OF ACTUALLY FILING AN
UNFAIR PRACTICE BEFORE PER. WE
ACTUALLY HOPE THAT THE STATURE
OF A FRAMEWORK PROVIDED BY AN
NDA. AND HAVING PROVES OVERSIGHT
WILL ACTUALLY REDUCE THE TOTAL
NUMBER OF DISPUTES
AND PARTICULARLY THOSE THAT WE
GET TO THE LEVEL OF HEADING
TOWARD SOMETHING LIKE PER. OKAY
AND THEY ALSO SAY THAT THIS IS
VERY COMPLICATED THEY'RE GONNA.
AN OUTSIDE CONSULTANT AND THEY
NEED THREE NEW PEOPLE TO
UNDERSTAND HOW THIS IS DONE.
BOB I THINK THAT'S UNFORTUNATE
BART HAS A VERY ROBUST LEGAL AND
LABOR RELATIONS TEAM WITH.
VERY TO EXPERIENCE PRIOR TO THAT
TIME THE BART INCLUDING SOME
THAT HAVE EXPERIENCE WORKING
UNDER AN MBA AND WHISPERED SO I.
FIND IT IS CHANGED INTERESTING
THAT THEY WOULD HAVE TO AUGMENT
THEIR STAFF TO. DO THIS FOR A
UNIT THAT ONLY TWO HUNDRED AND
SEVENTY MEMBERS. AND THAT WILL
LIKELY NOT RESULT IN VERY MANY
CASES ACTUALLY GOING TO PER.
AREN'T YOU MADE A GOOD CASE
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU SEE NO OTHER COMMENTS
I'D SAY WITH TWO HUNDRED SEVENTY
MEMBERS IF YOU HAVE MORE THAN
THREE OR FOUR PART COMPLAINTS
THAT MAYBE THERE'S PROMISED
MANAGEMENT SELF WITH THAT WOULD
YOU LIKE TO CLOSE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH VENTURE ALSO
WANT TO JUST INDICATE THAT.
OUR OFFICE HAS HELPED CONVENE
HOURS LONG MULTIPLE MEETINGS
WITH INTERESTED STAKE HOLDERS
ON%
ON BOTH SIDES AND WE CONTINUE TO
STAY COMMITTED TO THAT
CONVERSATION I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FIVE. THANK YOU THAT GETS OUT OF
THE ROLL CALL.
KALRA.
KALRA IT LOOKS LIKE AB TWENTY ME
EIGHTY FOUR ENJOYS A DO PASS
RECOMMENDATION.
I LEFT MY MISS RANSOM SECOND BY
MISTER PARK.
THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING EVERYONE. THANK
YOU MADAM CHAIR.
AB TWENTY EIGHTY FOUR ACQUIRES
ENTITIES PROVIDING COURT
REPORTING SERVICES TO REGISTER
WITH THE COURT REPORTER AS BORED
AS COURT REPORTING PROVIDERS IN
ORDER TO ACQUIRE.
PLANS TO THE SAME LAWS
REGULATIONS THAT DICTATE.
OF COURT REPORTING OTHER IS A
LOW ONE TIME STARTUP COST IN
MEANT THE BILL IN FOURSOMES
MINOR IN OBSERVABLE IN ADDITION
REGISTRATION FEES PERCENT AB
TWENTY FOUR MAY OFFSET THE
ONGOING COST TO THE BOARD.
BUT ME ON BEHALF COURT
REPORTERS IS YVONNE BETTER AND
ALSO HAVE REGIONAL GROUPS.
THANK YOU IN SUPPORT.
GOOD MORNING MY NAME IS THE FUND
VETERAN WITH THE COURT REPORTERS
BOARD WHERE SPONSORING THIS BILL
ON BEHALF OF THE COST CONSUMERS
OF CALIFORNIA. ON YOU HAVE THE
COSTS BEFORE YOU IN THIS THE.
ANALYSIS THEIR MINOR NO
SOLVABLE AND HERE TO ANSWER ANY
TECHNICAL QUESTIONS AND THERE'S
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE.
THANK YOU DIGITAL SUPPORTERS A
JIM GROSS ABOUT THE DEPOSITION
REPORTERS ASSOCIATION IN STRONG
SUPPORT.
ARE THERE ANY IN OPPOSITION.
AARON ROBERT WITH CALIFORNIA
ADVOCATES ON BEHALF OF THE
COALITION OF DEPOSITION FIRM
SERVICE FIRMS AND WE REMAIN
OPPOSED TO THE BILL IT'S
IDENTICAL TO ONE THAT WAS VETOED
LAST YEAR. I BELIEVE THE
REGISTRATION IS NOT NECESSARY IN
ADDITION ADDITIONALLY THERE'S
LITIGATION PENDING SAID LIKE TO
SEE THAT DECISION COME FORTH
BEFORE WE PURSUE ANY LEGISLATION
THANK YOU.
I'M A FINANCE NO FILE.
HE QUESTIONS.
WE JUST CLOSE.
BUT FAST RELIABLE AND THAT GETS
OUT ON B. ROLL CALL WITH MISTER
GALLAGHER VOTING AYE I THINK
YOU.
GREAT WE'RE DOWN TO LOOKING FOR
MR MCCARTY IN THREE MEMBERS OF
THIS COMMITTEE SO AGAINST
ACCLAIM ADDITIONAL MEMBERS OF
THIS COMMITTEE UP AND IT WOULD
BE GREAT IF THIS MCCARTY CAME AT
SOME POINT MR CHALLENGE LIKE TO
GO NEXT.
WELL WE'RE LOOKING FOR MISS
QUIRK SILVA TO THINK YOU.
AB TWENTY ONE SIXTY SEVEN ENJOYS
A DO PASS RECOMMENDATION.
AS AMENDED TO CORRECT AN
INADVERTENT AIR IN THE
DEFINITION OF MEDICAL
INFORMATION FROM A DIGITAL
HEALTH FEEDBACK SYSTEM BY
STRIKING THE PHRASE REGARDLESS
OF WHETHERINDIVIDUALLY IDENTIFY
ALL.
HOW THAT'S RIGHT I'M OFF THANK
YOU VERY MUCH MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS SO? ARE WE WILL ACCEPT
THE AMENDMENT AS STATED BY THE
CHAIR AND OF THE BILL TWENTY ONE
SIX SEVEN WITH THE FINE DIGITAL
HEALTH FEEDBACK SYSTEMS TO
INCLUDE. ITEMS SUCH AS DIGITAL
PILLS.
WHICH OF PHARMACEUTICALS AND
AND UP THE BILL ESPECIALLY WILL.
SAY THAT CMI A APPLIES TO
INFORMATION DERIVED FROM THIS
THE CITY VICES AND WITH THAT I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR ABOUT THANK
YOU THERE IS A MOTION BY MISTER
QUIRK A SECOND BY MYSTERIOUS ARE
THERE ANY.
SPEAKERS IN SUPPORT.
SPEAKERS IN OPPOSITION.
DEPARTMENT FINANCE NO FILE.
WOULD YOU LIKE CLOSE MR CHANCE I
RESPECTFULLY ASK RIGHT BACK
ECONOMY ROLL CALL THINK YOU.
MS EGGMAN WOULD YOU LIKE TO
PRESENT.
TWENTY THREE SIXTEEN ENJOYS A DO
PASS RECOMMENDATION.
.
TWENTY FOUR SIXTEEN WHICH WAS ON
CONSENT BUT WAS FOR THE LAST
MINUTETHIS ALLOWS US AND. OF
FOR PEOPLE WHO DO MENTAL HEALTH
ADVOCACY TO HAVE THEIR TRAINING
AVAILABLE TO THEM ONLINE.
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR IBOOK.
TWENTY THREE SIX.
YES.
I'M HOME FROM THE BUS DEATHLY
NOT DOES NOT WAS I AND I AM NOT
SURE QUIRK SILVA ARE NOT SHARE
AND.
.
ALRIGHT WE HAVE A MOTION SIR YOU
MAKE A MOTION BY MISTER QUIRK A
SECOND BY MISTER OBERNOLTE OUR
SPEAKERS IN SUPPORT.
SPEAKERS IN OPPOSITION.
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE NO FILE.
WOULD YOU LIKE TO.
CLOSE.
I AM NOT SHARON QUIRK SILVA
NIGHT LIKE YOU'RE HAVING. AND
THAT GETS OUT ON AND A ROLL CALL
THINK.
WE'RE JUST THROWING UP ALL KINDS
NUMBERS ON THAT BOOK.
THANK YOU I AM LOOKING FOR
SHARON QUIRK SILVA THOUGH AND
KEVIN MCCARTY IF THEY COULD COME
DOWN TO PRESENT THEIR BILLS THAT
WOULD BE AWESOME.
AT YET WE HAVE MYSTERIOUS THOUGH
IN THE MEANTIME SHE WOULD IT.
I WILL NEED TO HAVE PRESENT ON
A. B. EIGHTEEN SIXTY SEVEN IT
ENJOYS A DO PASS RECOMMENDATION.
AB EIGHTEEN SIXTY SEVEN THE
TRACK ACT.
TRACKING RECORDS AND COMPLAINTS
REQUIRES EMPLOYERS OF FIFTY OR
MORE EMPLOYEES TO RETAIN
EMPLOYEE COMPLAINTS FILED
THROUGH THE INTERNAL COMPLAINT
PROCESS OF THE EMPLOYER FOR A
PERIOD OF TEN YEARS FROM THE
DATE OF FILING. MOVE THE BILL.
THIS BILL AUTHORIZES DEPARTMENT
A D. FE H. DEPARTMENT FOR
EMPLOYMENT HOUSING. TO SEEK AN
ORDER COMPLIANCE ONE EMPLOYEE
VIOLATES THE RECORD KEEPING
REQUIREMENTS.
COSTS ARE MINOR AND THAT SORT OF
THING.
THANK YOU WE HAVE A MOTION BY
MISTER QUIRK.
AS.
SECOND BY MISTER CHOW.
.
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR IVAN.
DELUDE HAVE SUPPORTERS.
WITH LOTS OF SUPPORTERS BUT.
NOBODY SPEAKING TODAY OF I'M.
AND THE MANAGER MEMBERS MICHAEL
YEARS YOU ARE WITH THE
CALIFORNIA PLANET LAWYERS
ASSOCIATION. JUST WANTED I
REITERATE THAT BETTER RECORD
TENSION POLICIES WE THINK WILL
REDUCE.
THESE TYPES OF SEXUAL
HARASSMENT CLAIMS OR YOUR
SUPPORT.
THANK YOU LOOKS LIKE WE HAVE
SOME IN OPPOSITION.
WHEN I REMIND FOLKS THAT WE CAN
HAVE TWO SPEAKERS IN OPPOSITION
PART TWO MINUTES EACH AND TO
PLEASE KEEP YOUR COMMENTS TO
FISCAL ANALYSIS AGAIN.
GOOD MORNING LOWER CURTIS ON THE
HALF OF THE CALIFORNIA CHAMBER
OF COMMERCE THANK YOU SO MUCH
FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO TESTIFY
TODAY I WILL KEEP IT BRIEF THERE
IS A FISCAL IMPACT FOR EMPLOYERS
DOCUMENT RETENTION DOES
ACTUALLY.
COST EMPLOYERS MONEY EITHER TO
DO IT ONLINE OR TO USE UP PRIME
OFFICE SPACE FOR DOCUMENTS AND
WE ARE SORRY AND OPPOSE UNLESS
AMENDED POSITION WITH THIS BILL
WE ARE ASKING. THE AUTHOR
INSTEAD OF A FLAT TENURE
REQUIREMENT THAT IT BE FOR THE
LENGTH OF EMPLOYMENT PLUS THREE
YEARS IN SOME INSTANCES THAT
WILL BE LONGER IT WOULD BE THE
LENGTH OF EMPLOYMENT OF THE
ACCUSED PLUS THREE YEARS. WHICH
WOULD STREAMLINED DOCUMENT
RETENTION BECAUSE CURRENTLY MOST
THE MAJORITY OF DOCUMENT
RETENTION REQUIREMENTS ARE THREE
YEARS UNTIL WOULD STREAMLINE
THAT WITH THE CURRENT FAIR
EMPLOYMENT HOUSING REQUIREMENTS
AND OTHER PERSONNEL FILE
DOCUMENT REQUIREMENTS. THANK YOU
SO MUCH FOR THAT BUT YOU JUST BY
TODAY.
THANK YOU ADDITIONAL OPPOSITION.
MADAM CHAIR CHRISTMAS KAYLEE ON
BEHALF OF THAT CALIFORNIA
AMBULANCE ASSOCIATION WE'VE BEEN
WORKING WITH THE AUTHOR INNER
STAFF AND HOPEFULLY SHE'LL. TAKE
OUR REQUESTED AMENDMENT THANK
YOU.
AND LIVE WORK ON BEHALF OF THE
FAMILY BUSINESS ASSOCIATION IN
OPPOSITION.
AND THE CALL RISE CALIFORNIA
MANUFACTURES A TECHNOLOGY
ASSOCIATION WE TO YOU ARE POSING
AS AMENDED THANK YOU.
THANK YOU DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE
NO FILE.
SEE NO QUESTIONS WOULD YOU LIKE
TO CLOSE.
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR
VOTE.
THAT GETS OUT ON A B. ROLL CALL
WITH MR FUNG NOT VOTING AND
MISTER GALLAGHER NOT VOTING.
THINK.
I'VE BEEN INFORMED.
THAT MR MCCARTY IT'S NOT IN THE
BUILDING HE.
BRING GIVEN COUPLE MINUTES WHILE
WE GET THROUGH THE REST OF
BUSINESS TO SEE IF HE SHOWS UP
IF NOT WE'LL JUST PUT IS BUILT
OVER TIME NEXT WEEK.
BEFORE WE TAKE A MOTION AND READ
THE CONSENT CALENDAR I WANNA
KNOW THAT AB TWENTY NINE NINETY
SIX.
LONG HAS BEEN PUT OVER FOR NEXT
WEEK AND.
.
AB TWENTY FOUR TWENTY
QUICKSILVER IS ON THE CONSENT
CALENDAR WAS.
ERRONEOUSLY. WITHOUT A TAKE
EMOTIONAL CONSENT CALENDAR.
THE MOTION BY MISTER CALDERON A
SECOND BY MISTER.
OBERNOLTE.
I'M.
MY BRAIN WENT DEAD I'M SORRY
THAT IT TOO MANY VOICES.
OUTSIDE MY BRAIN NOT INSIDE AND
WITH THAT PLEASE READ THE CAN
SECULAR.
IN EIGHTEEN.
AB EIGHTEEN NINETY EIGHTEEN
NINETY ONE EIGHTEEN NINETY FOUR
NINETEEN FIFTY FOUR NINETEEN
EIGHTY SIX NINETEEN NINETY SIX
TWENTY SEVENTY. TWENTY NINETY
SIX TWENTY ONE FORTY TO TWENTY
ONE NINETY SIX TWENTY TO THIRTY
EIGHT. TWENTY TWO FIFTY SIX
TWENTY TWO SIXTY SEVEN TWENTY
TWO NINETY ONE TWENTY THREE TEN
TWENTY THREE EIGHTY EIGHT TWENTY
FOUR TWENTY TWENTY FOUR SEVENTY
FIVE TWENTY FIVE NINETY FOUR.
TWENTY SIX ZERO THREE TWENTY SIX
TWENTY TWO SO OUT OF ORDER
TWENTY FOUR TWENTY.
TWENTY SIX FIFTY FOUR TWENTY SIX
FIFTY SIX TWENTY SIX EIGHTY NINE
TWENTY SEVEN NINETEEN TWENTY
SEVEN TWENTY. TWENTY SEVEN
THIRTY TWENTY SEVEN THIRTY FIVE
TWENTY SEVEN FIFTY TWENTY EIGHT
EIGHTY SIX
TWENTY NINE FIFTY TWO TWENTY
NINE EIGHTY THREE THIRTY FORTY.
THIRTY ONE I ONE THIRTY ONE
SIXTY FOUR THIRTY TO. TWELVE
THIRTY TWO TWENTY NINE THIRTY TO
FORTY SIX AND S. B. NINE FOUR
ONE.
THAT IS HAS A MOTION A SECOND
AND GETS OUT ON A ROLL CALL AND.
IF YOU WILL NOW CALLED THE BILLS
THAT HAVE BEEN MOVED TO THE
SUSPENSE FILE.
AB SEVENTEEN FIFTY ONE SEVENTEEN
FIFTY TO SEVENTEEN FIFTY THREE
SEVENTEEN NINETY THREE EIGHTEEN
OH ONE EIGHTEEN SEVENTY.
EIGHTEEN SEVENTY ONE NINETEEN OH
TWO NINETEEN SIXTEEN NINETEEN
THIRTY THREE NINETEEN THIRTY
FIVE NINETEEN FORTY NINE
NINETEEN FIFTY ONE NINETEEN
FIFTY FIVE. NINETEEN FIFTY NINE
NINETEEN SIXTY THREE TWO
THOUSAND SIX TWO THOUSAND TWENTY
FIVE TWO THOUSAND FORTY SIX TWO
THOUSAND SIXTY FIVE. TWENTY ONE
TWENTY TWENTY ONE TWENTY FOUR
TWENTY ONE SIXTY TWENTY ONE
EIGHTY NINE TWENTY ONE NINETY
FIVE TWENTY TO SIXTY ONE. TWENTY
TWO SIXTY EIGHT TWENTY THREE OH
THREE TWENTY THREE OH FIVE 23-14
TWENTY THREE THIRTY FOUR TWENTY
THREE THIRTY SIX TWENTY THREE
FORTY THREE. TWENTY THREE
SEVENTY TWENTY THREE SEVENTY
FIVE TWENTY FOUR EIGHTEEN TWENTY
FOUR THIRTY THREE TWENTY FOUR
THIRTY FOUR TWENTY FOUR THIRTY
SIX TWENTY FOUR FORTY SIX TWENTY
FOUR NINETY TWO.
TWENTY FOUR NINETY THREE TWENTY
FOUR NINETY EIGHT TWENTY FIVE
HUNDRED TWENTY FIVE ALL FOUR
TWENTY FIVE FOURTEEN TWENTY FIVE
FIFTEEN. TWENTY FIVE FORTY SEVEN
TWENTY FIVE SIXTY EIGHT TWENTY
FIVE SEVENTY EIGHT TWENTY FIVE
NINETY NINE. TWENTY SIX OH SIX
TWENTY SIX THIRTEEN TWENTY SIX
TWENTY EIGHT TWENTY SIX SIXTY
TWO TWENTY SIX SEVENTY FOUR
TWENTY SIX SEVENTY SIX TWENTY
SEVEN ELEVEN. TWENTY SEVEN
TWENTY FOUR TWENTY SEVEN TWENTY
EIGHT TWENTY SEVEN FIFTY ONE
TWENTY SEVEN FIFTY EIGHT TWENTY
SEVEN EIGHTY FOUR TWENTY EIGHT
ELEVEN TWENTY EIGHT THIRTEEN
TWENTY EIGHT TWENTY THREE.
TWENTY EIGHT THIRTY TWENTY EIGHT
FORTY TWENTY EIGHT FORTY FIVE
TWENTY EIGHT FORTY SIX TWENTY
EIGHT FIFTY FIVE TWENTY EIGHT
SIXTY FIVE TWENTY EIGHT SIXTY
EIGHT TWENTY EIGHT NINETY THREE.
TWENTY NINE OH SIX TWENTY NINE
TEN.
TWENTY NINE THIRTY TWENTY NINE
SEVENTY ONE TWENTY NINE EIGHTY
EIGHT TWENTY NINE NINETY TWO
THREE THOUSAND EIGHT THREE
THOUSAND SIXTY ONE. THREE
THOUSAND EIGHTY FOUR THREE
THOUSAND EIGHTY NINE THIRTY ONE
THIRTY SIX THIRTY ONE THIRTY
SEVEN THIRTY ONE EIGHTY SIX
THIRTY TWO THIRTEEN AND THIRTY
TO FIFTY SEVEN.
WE GET LONGER AND NOW WE'LL MOVE
ON TO. MR MCCARTY SPILL.
THIS FLETCHER I BELIEVE YOU WANT
TO PRESENT IS THE TWENTY FOUR
EIGHTY SEVEN. I SHARE WELL AB
TRADE BILL MOVE IT.
I WOULD LIKE TO CONTINUE THESE
COSTS ARE MINORS OR WHY
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE.
ON BEHALF MISTER MCCARTY DO YOU
HAVE ANY WITNESSES.
SEEING NONE.
WOULD ANYONE FROM THE AUDIENCE
LIKE TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT.
OPPOSITION GOING ONCE.
WE HAVE ONE.
THANK YOU ALL RIGHT SPENCER ON
BEHALF OF THE AMERICAN COLLEGE
OF OBSTETRICIANS GYNECOLOGISTS
DIGIT NINE IN THE CALVARY
CADMIUM PHYSICIANS ON BOTH
CURRENT HAVE OPPOSE ON THE BILL
WE HAD SOME VERY GOOD
DISCUSSIONS WITH THE AUTHOR. IS
OPEN THAT ARE CONCERNS WILL BE
MAD AS THE BILL MOVES TOWARD
THANK YOU.
DEPARTMENT FINANCED NEVADA.
VERY MUCH QUESTIONS COMMENTS
FROM
MEMBERS.
SEEING NONE.
I BELIEVE THIS BILL.
IT'S OUT WITH REPUBLICANS NOT
VOTING.
MISTER BIGELOW IN MISTER
OBERNOLTE VOTING NO.
ALRIGHT AND THAT CONCLUDES OUR
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE WE WILL
GO AHEAD.
WE'RE GONNA.
EVERYBODY'S HEARING GO AHEAD AND
CLOSE THE MEETING WITHOUT
THINKING.
ADJOURNED